what is critical race theory critical
race theory is calling everything that
you want to control racist until you
control it
a collegiate theory which centers the
idea that
modern discussions
around race relations impose a kind of
false neutrality that there's an
assumption of racial neutrality that
we've overcome systemic issues when we
really haven't
welcome to episode 134 of the michaela
peterson podcast in this opposing views
style episode i interviewed two people
to discuss a topic often controversial
james lindsey and vosh join me to
discuss critical race theory we covered
a range of topics surrounding crt
starting with what it is according to
two different sides and what it's
theoretically trying to solve where it's
taught the ideology behind it and what
we can do about it if anything
we also discuss social biases
anti-capitalism
the idea of whiteness and the over-focus
on race that's so prevalent today
or the reasonable focus on race
according to one of the guests
james lindsay is an american author
mathematician and political commentator
best known for the hoax papers he helped
submit to social science journals one of
them won a prize for outstanding
scholarship
bosch is an american left-wing youtuber
and he often has political debates with
other content creators like twitch's
destiny he identifies as a libertarian
socialist and anti-fascist
i hope you guys enjoy this episode if
you do please consider subscribing
before we get into it this episode is
sponsored by schwenk 1500 degree grills
as you know i'm quite experienced and
pretty picky about how i cook my meat
wanks american-made grills are about the
best you'll find anywhere they're very
easy to clean and you get beautiful
steakhouse quality steaks in about three
minutes it's equally good for cooking
chicken wings hamburgers lamb veggies
whatever and since most of you like
pizza it comes with a pizza stone these
grills are made in america they go up to
1500 degrees fahrenheit but don't smoke
are super easy to clean and they're
portable so you could be grilling on
your patio one day and out camping the
next
they're clean looking and if you're
looking to impress someone with your
cooking skills this is the way to go
head to
swankgrills.com today and get 150 off a
schwank 1500 degree grill when using
promo code mp at checkout again that's
150 off one of these sweet girls over at
schwenkgrills.com
with codemp at checkout
james lindsay welcome back to the
podcast
hey
great to be here
okay so this episode we're going to be
talking about critical race theory your
opinions on critical race theory so be a
good one
i don't have very many positive opinions
about it just to put that out there from
the front
okay well that's why you're here
but before we get started if anybody
doesn't know who you are can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what you do
yes uh so my name is james lindsey and i
guess it was a brief background i
studied physics as an undergraduate i
studied mathematics
for my doctorate which i finished in
2010
at the university of tennessee and since
2017 or so i've primarily
studied
critical theories uh
especially started in gender studies and
then it went into critical race theory
and then into fat studies and disability
studies and all of these other kind of
critical theories of identity
for
more or less all of the time since in
2018 we released this kind of spoof
project that everybody uh i think in the
world has heard about now called the
grievance studies affair where we had
written a bunch of fake academic
articles for high-level academic
journals in these fields including the
leading feminist philosophy journal
seven of those articles were accepted in
the course of about a year so we
demonstrated some knowledge of the field
and in the process we uncovered you know
that this scholarship is is in fact very
concerning
and wanted to learn more so we
deepened our research wrote a book that
came out and
came out last year called cynical
theories that summarizes the postmodern
components of this and i founded a
company also last year called new
discourses that puts out as much
information about this as i can so i am
literally a full-time researcher
writer and speaker about
uh critical theory post-modernism
marxism before that et cetera and so
critical race theory has been the
primary project that i've been engaged
in since
probably october
2019
through
uh quite recently and which point i
finally figured that i've said all i
need to say about it other than to do
dialogue or to answer questions for
people
okay well that's why you're here so
let's let's start off with
what is critical race theory and what
problem is it trying to solve
uh critical race theory is it depends i
could give you about 10 different
definitions for it it depends on how
simple you want them and how
how much fidelity you want that
definition to have to the critical race
theory literature categories theory
sells itself as a critical theory of
race in other words uh it is the fusion
according to its creator uh kimberly
crenshaw is the one who came up with the
name at least critical race theory she
credits her mentor derek bell as being
you know a co-founder of the ideas with
her they're both harvard law uh scholars
uh originally
but she said that it was cr that they
were critical theorists who were
interested in racial justice advocacy
and racial justice advocates who are
doing critical theory so the name
critical race theory naturally falls out
and so it's very simple to understand
critical race theory then as a critical
theory which is an adaptation of marxism
through the 20th century to answer the
question of what do we do with the fact
that the
capitalism stabilizes the working class
over time
uh so that's what critical theory is
it's a new form of marxism that evolved
in the 20th century and then that
centers race instead of centering
economic class as the primary
object of interest
and so that's why it's called critical
race theory and so we have the exact
quote for example from another critical
race theorist from the 1990s named
gloria ladson billings
who is a big education theorist she
works currently in education all across
the country but very heavily in virginia
where she was one of the lead authors of
what's called ad equity virginia
further department of education right
now
and
gloria ledson billing says in her paper
toward a critical race theory of
education from 1995 that the point of
critical race theory is to make race the
central construct for understanding
inequality and uh it adapts all of that
marxian theoretical uh
idea
as it got modified through critical
theory into a new paradigm that centers
race as the primary stratifying force in
society
so
that's a definition that i think blends
theirs with my interpretation of it
which would be that it's race marxism uh
in a two-word simple summary this
marxism using race as the center
object to understand inequality there
are a lot of other ways we could
characterize it we could say that
critical race theory is the it is a
belief system that
by doing what i just said uh
regards racism created by white people
as the or fundamental organizing
principle of society
so
and in fact white it should be racism
that benefits white people because they
say that white people created
racism in their own benefit for their
own benefit and that's what a critical
theory always does is that power creates
circumstances such that its own benefit
is maintained and that when it's a
critical theory it is that that power
structure then in a sense almost
brainwashes society to accept the the
terms upon which that power structure
depends uh which is a recreation of
marx's superstructure and ideologist
thinking you know standing over the the
proletariat working class base that does
all the production so it's literally
just a reproduction of marxism using
race as a proxy for culture and then
cultural marxism as the tool
to uh analyze race as a proxy for
culture
uh or more simply critical race theory
is calling everything that you want to
control racist until you control it
okay so then why is it that when you
hear from people
pro critical race theory they're talking
about it as a way to even the kind of
even the scales or to make everything
more equal for people who've had had it
harder for generations
because i mean well you just said it
right so their their belief is that that
everything works in terms of if we go
back to marx with the idea of of a base
that then has a superstructure that's
risen above that and the superstructure
becomes self-perpetuating and designs
how society is going to operate the idea
is that if there was a system say like
when the united states was founded
slavery was still a part of the united
states despite the declaration of
independence saying all men are created
equal but that system itself is going to
be self-sustaining and in fact it will
do so it will sustain itself in ways
that are more and more difficult to see
what appears to be progress is in fact
not progress it is say with critical
race theory racism learning to hide
itself better or if it were older
marxism it's bourgeois ideology learning
to hide itself better and so critical
race theorists say that the the racial
differences that the system that we
currently inhabit western civilization
if you want to call it that but it's too
broad really it's kind of post
enlightenment uh british enlightenment
more specifically uh
western civilization in particularly
america and that which flowed from
american-ness was created in a system of
white supremacy and whiteness and so
that white supremacy is
self-perpetuating such that the people
involved don't always even usually don't
even know that they're involved in
perpetuating it and so what you need is
a critical theory that can make that
oppression visible so the proponents of
it say that unless we have people who
are able to see the way that racism
works in this more subtle hidden
regards and who can understand how it's
systemic and structural rather than
something that mere individuals or
institutions might participate in unless
we learn to see it as a systemic
structural thing that hides itself from
the people
that benefit from it and therefore are
motivated to maintain it or to at least
ignore it then it's not possible to get
rid of it and so
it's a um
they hold themselves up as the people
the only people who can see the true
nature of racism and so everybody else
who's fighting racism is actually doing
a poor job and it's just helping racism
hide itself better so
people who believe in critical race
theory believe if we're going to give
them as much charity as possible given
that they are ultimately marxists
but they they believe that racism cannot
be overturned while the existing system
remains
to give you an anchor for that in the
book critical race theory and
introduction on page three at the end of
the first paragraph this is a book from
2001
written at the high school level because
it's not in schools
by richard delgado and gene stefan chick
richard delgado being one of the
founding members of critical race theory
who was present at the meeting in 1989
when critical race theory got its name
by kimberly crenshaw uh he wrote in that
paragraph he says unlike traditional
approaches to civil rights which embrace
incrementalism and step-by-step progress
critical race theory calls into question
the very foundations of the liberal
order
uh including equality theory legal
reasoning enlightenment rationalism and
the neutral principles of constitutional
law that's literally exactly a quote in
their own words so they don't embrace
incrementalism they don't embrace
embrace step-by-step progress because
they believe the system itself is the
problem so you must have a revolution in
the system to overcome racism that
revolution calls into question the very
foundations of the liberal order which
include equality theory so they think
that the playing field is automatically
tilted by those power dynamics racism or
white supremacy so that uh you can't
treat people as equals because if you
treat people as equals what it actually
does is multiplies inequality this is by
the way a reproduction of marx's
argument against the nuclear family
which he said was a capitalist creation
so that wealthy families could pass
their bourgeois wealth onto the next
generation so the rich would get richer
and the poor would get poorer it's just
a reproduction of that so you can't have
equality theory you can't have legal
reasoning
because the law is said to be created
within the system to benefit the people
that are at the top of that system so
rule of law
is going to be considered to be actually
a white supremacist construct that
maintains white supremacy even if the
people involved don't realize it that
racism is hidden in the law and you'll
actually see the critical race theory
arose out of legal scholarship critical
legal scholarship that centered race and
they they claim from the very beginning
that that the point was that the law
encodes racism in secret hidden ways and
a critical theory of race is necessary
to uncover it
enlightenment rationalism is a way of
knowing like i said it's the british
enlightenment that they're actually
rejecting and so we're not going to be
rational they say in fact that nobody's
rational everybody's got vested
interests that they uh aren't critically
examining and so we have to get rid of
this idea that anybody can be a neutral
observer
or be actually genuinely rational and
they prefer instead if we want to go all
the way back to rousseau the russoian
idea that sincerity and sentimentality
actually are better markers of truth
than rationalism and reason and then
finally they reject uh or call into
question let's not overstate it neutral
principles of constitutional law
um which is to say again the neutrality
for them reproduces inequality uh they
believe in fact
robin d'angelo has written in a book
called is everyone really equal that
originally the kind of people working in
civil rights in the related movements
believed that
neutrality and liberal humanism was the
way to go but they suddenly they
realized very early on this is on page
five of the first edition of that book
by the way you can look it up um that
instead that they had to reject liberal
humanism because actually what
things like equality and neutrality do
is that they fool this is her exact word
they fool racial minorities and other
minority sexual minorities for example
outside of critical race theory into
believing that they have more
opportunity and freedom than societal
structures
marx actually allow and so you can
actually see that this is exactly what i
said it is in when we start invoking
their own words i didn't i came to this
conclusion about critical race theory
very reluctantly and if you need proof
of that read cynical theories where i
say repeatedly it's not marxism i was
wrong it's marxism
okay
so
people who are kind of pushing this
theory in schools and like elementary
schools for example
are for instance
the teachers doing that
are they just not aware of this
is it just the people at the top at a
high level that are aware of this or how
how how many people are actually aware
of this versus thinking that they're
just making
the world more equal well in that i'm
not a critical theorist and don't claim
to be able to read the contents of
people's unconscious i i don't know um
many people certainly think that they're
doing the best that they can to try to
end racial inequity or to create more
fairness and opportunity etc and i don't
want to
claim that i can speak over what they're
saying some people would certainly know
what this is about um
kimberly crenshaw is
knows she's doing a critical theory for
example richard delgado in his in an
interview he gave a few years after the
founding of critical race theory
explicitly said that they were a bunch
of marxists and so he knew that it's a
marxian-based theory charles mills uh
writes at length he has a book called
from class to race where he tracks his
own journey in fact it's an excellent
analysis of marxism it's one of the best
i've ever read not to take i'm not just
saying these people are crazy or stupid
people they're actually some of them are
brilliant and uh charles mills writes
this excellent critique of marxism and
explains how his thinking
uh in the birth of critical race theory
and the critical philosophy of race
involves a transformation of seeing
classes too simplistic and race as being
more nuanced and sophisticated uh so
you know i don't know if charles mills
knows that he's being
still a marxist it seems to read his own
book that he does not he thinks that
he's left marxism behind
kimberly crenshaw repeatedly claims that
she felt like there had to be these
re-nuancing of things but then kimberly
crenshaw goes on television lies she
says that there's no connection between
she went on joy read and said that
there's no connection between marxism
and actually she didn't say that she got
asked plain blank by joyride
is this marxism using race and she went
well
and then
filibustered for two minutes until the
next question came up she didn't
actually answer the question at all
which suggests to me that she does know
that it's marx's amusing race uh so i
don't know i think the majority of what
i'm finding in school district after
school district going around the country
and talking to people is that the
majority of people are going along along
either because they think it's generally
good
um but they're getting squeamish now is
what i'm also finding uh that they are
afraid not to go along because they're
going to get accused of being a racist
or a white supremacist which is the kind
of core trick that um critical race
theory pulls on people who disagree with
it they call them racist and white
supremacist
and then some usually it's a fairly
small number do know what they're doing
for example i spoke recently with a
school district
parents from a school district in texas
who showed me that the the coordinator
that they brought in for the school
that's bringing the critical race theory
into the school system there
said that equity is based in critical
consciousness which means he would know
that it's a marxist tool
raising a critical consciousness of race
is the point of critical race theory and
so raising a critical consciousness in
the students he must know something he
so i can't guess what people know and
what people don't know i don't pretend
to to read their minds i wrote an essay
last year and said that the ideology
itself is psychopathic and so people who
engage in it reproduces psychopathy
whether they are psychopaths or not and
so that distinguishes between what we
might call a
essential psychopathy which is something
wrong in your brain and a functional
psychopathy that happens when you play
out along a say a cult dynamic or
whatever say to draw back to the people
that were in jim jones's cult were
functionally psychopathic they were not
mentally well but that's because they
were living out the dictates of the cult
and so the ideology itself in this case
i believe is is racist and psychopathic
and i don't know who is a true believer
who's going along because they're afraid
who's going along because they don't
really understand kind of water carrying
useful idiots and then uh who actually
is a you know in the know driver of it
in fact it's totally possible that very
few people involved in critical race
theory realize what it actually is
because you very rarely
but unlike charles mills you very rarely
see them saying it so explicitly
just keep notes
a lot of words here that i don't
understand so how i i feel like a lot of
so when i went to university i had i was
i was in psychology but i had a lot of
friends who were in sociology or
anthropology and they were writing
essays and learning words and i was just
like that looks like marxism because i
read some book
okay i can't remember what the book was
it was either describing marxism or
maybe
i i don't remember what it was but i
remember seeing the same words written
so how is it that
these specific words have infiltrated
into society so well because something
like what did you just say critical
consciousness like if somebody just said
that to the yeah they'd be like oh okay
i don't under i guess i don't understand
that i guess i won't ask any questions
in case i look stupid
there are kind of four mechanisms by
which it infiltrates um
one of which you've just named but i'll
kind of summarize them one is that they
use a technique that's called strategic
equivocation where the word a word like
critical means two things at once
it means something very specific as in
the critical marxist tradition and at
this on the other hand it means
something like critical thinking or
being skeptical asking hard questions
and you if you squint your eyes and kind
of you know like those those 3d puzzles
if you're going to blur out your eyes
you can see both meanings kind of being
similar to one another
like diversity means having different
perspectives but if you only consider
the perspectives authentic if they
express a critical consciousness of
identity then it's really they're all
still saying the exact same thing which
is a critical theory you can see how the
words mean two different things at once
but sort of the same and this is one of
the mechanisms it's called strategic
equivocation
the philosopher nicholas shackle in his
paper from 2005 called the
the vacuity of postmodern
methodology
refers to this as
the their martin bailey rhetorical
strategy which has gained a lot of
purchase now people have heard of the
martin bailey so you have one meaning
that is a very defensible meaning normal
everyday meaning common parlance one
meaning that is a very activist meaning
uh and we don't have to get into what a
montavely are to understand that you
know you have the meaning you have when
you're in trouble and you have the
meaning you have when you're advancing
an agenda and you switch back and forth
between them and that's basically what
it boils down to so strategically
verification on everyday terms and who
in the world is going to
and say oh could you clarify what you
mean by diversity because i don't really
know what all right could you clarify
inclusion for me i don't understand that
word nobody's ever going to say that and
so by having a
you can use that both defensively where
you get called on something and you can
say no it's just blah blah and say the
nicer thing instead of the activist
thing or you can use it offensively by
say
you know you're in a faculty meeting or
an administration meeting or whatever
and it says you know we're writing a new
curriculum for the school for the next
decade or new new policy for the school
or an agenda five year plan whatever it
happens to be and somebody says well
let's put focus on diversity in there
and people say well that sounds good you
know that's diversity is good and
nobody's going to ask what do you mean
by diversity and so everybody assumes it
means the normal thing and then
the second it becomes policy and
enforceable well now let's clarify the
definition of the thing that we just
made policy and it actually means that
people are experts in diversity which
means that they have you know a unique
voice of color that's authentic to the
theory and all of a sudden they've
brought it in so that's one mechanism
that they use the other is what you
mentioned which is um formally it would
be known as draining epistemic authority
uh it's to use words and make people
feel too dumb like i don't know what
that means but the other person's smart
so they used big words it must be they
must know more than me
and so i'm not qualified to push back or
other people watching will say well
they're using big formal technical terms
and you sound stupid uh by comparison so
we're going to listen to the person with
the big words and the degree so dreaming
draining epistemic authority in other
words making you look like you don't
know what you're talking about and that
they do know what they're talking about
which is an illusion in fact the
post-modernists warned about this john
franco leotard warned about this when he
talks about legitimation by purology
but in in in the post-modern condition
in 1979. so you know we were warned and
we didn't listen because the posterology
parology yes felt false logic
okay a fake logic that lies beyond
beside logic para paralogy so nice like
a second
like parallel word is like the literal
roots parallel word
parallel logic and so
yeah there you go and so keeping notes
here
make making people who disagree look
like they don't know what they're
talking about as a mechanism making them
look like they're morally deficient is
another draining of moral authority
and call you racist sexist so you're
trying to uphold your own benefit
whatever um
and
then the third is draining psychological
authority which is to say to gaslight
you to say this isn't really happening
you've misinterpreted it you didn't
understand the literature correctly only
we understand the literature correctly
marx pulled the same trick he said only
socialist man could understand socialist
theory correctly so if you didn't you
know
that's you know whether you want to say
that that's epistemic authority or
psychological authority uh certainly in
the soviet union they classified people
who didn't go along with the soviet
ideology as crazy as psychologically
deficient and we can read from
literature in the 1970s say by patricia
bydol or judith katz
who judas cats for white awareness and
she's the sole citation on that infamous
white supremacy culture thing that the
smithsonian museum put out last summer
that they quickly retracted the
infamous infographic that had you know
white supremacy culture includes things
like loyalty hard work uh punctuality
and all of these things well what what
they these authors judith katz in
particular but also patricia bidel
before her
wrote in the 1970s as kind of
proto-critical whiteness studies uh
theorists
they were both feminists what they wrote
was that
that whiteness and white supremacy are a
form of schizophrenia so they were
psychologizing
uh
they were psychologizing this position
so people who who subscribe to this are
psychologically deficient and shouldn't
be listened to so
causing making their opponents look
stupid crazy or evil
while simultaneously playing word games
with double meanings of words in a very
strategic way is the way they were able
to bring it in at the theoretical level
um creating parallel journals parallel
like you know you you write your
critical theory paper of say nutrition
critical nutrition studies israel and
they they wrote a book and i read it and
they said well we were submitting our
papers to nutrition journals and the
nutrition journal said this isn't
nutrition we're not accepting this and
so they made their own journal critical
nutrition studies and then six seven
years down the road
it's got some legs under it it's become
something there's a small conference
etcetera and then they say well regular
nutrition studies is actually um
chauvinist because it won't include us
and we're just advocating on behalf of
you know race sex gender ability status
indigeneity whatever these you know
markers are of identity and they won't
include our work even though it doesn't
meet the standards so creating that
parallel thing again the porology again
and kind of uh creating false legitimacy
for themselves in that regard is another
mechanism that they gained institutional
uh support and then when we get to not
to divert into this because i don't
think it's terribly interesting but the
the real real real story is in the late
2000 zeros before as into the early
2010s basically rivers of money went
into this because certain
big players on the world stage realized
just how
powerful of a tool it is to achieve
divide and conquer kind of ends
and specifically would have broken up
occupy wall street with it
because that was a big threat to the big
banks so all of a sudden you know
goldman sachs etc are all behind
these kind of intersectional and uh
progressive stack programs that
ultimately broke
occupy wall street as a strategic
maneuver and this just kind of blossomed
into this huge thing rivers and rivers
and rivers of money started to flow into
millions of dollars bill and melinda
gates have given tens of millions of
dollars
to initiatives that bring this into
education for example
one can only guess at what their actual
motivations are for doing that
i think i asked you this in the last
podcast we had but you do you sleep okay
this is horrifying
it's it's worse whatever you think it is
it's worse than you think but i didn't
for a long time and then i actually it's
a sad story and i literally um i work
myself to exhaustion every day and i
pass out completely uh and that's how i
sleep so
okay
i
okay i do that too i think so you also
go numb after a while like oh yeah it's
just that again okay whatever just
global tyranny all right you know
the critical race theory by the way is
the lock pick it's not itself global
tyranny if you think that these big
elites give a rat's ass about racial
minorities you are so missing the point
it is not about that it is the tool
because it's so extremely divisive and
so extremely personal and so extremely
effective it is a tool that they use
to be able to shuttle in uh broader
objectives that we talked about in the
previous podcast
okay so this is
okay so how far
how far entrenched are we in crt like
where is it being taught at the moment
every school system in the united states
probably with an overwhelming emphasis
on the richer ones i bet you if you went
so there are roughly 14 000 school
districts in the united states and if
you wanted to find out
the 150 the one percent approximately
that are the worst i bet you you could
just this is low resolution it wouldn't
be totally accurate but i bet you if you
went down the list of the top three
richest school districts in each state
and nailed those 150 down i bet you find
more emphasis on pushing critical race
theory in one guise or another whether
it's ethnic studies culturally
responsive teaching culturally
sustaining teaching you know any of
those kind of culturally something or
another
education uh it'll be brought in as a
part of a broader program of social
emotional learning for example um
you'll find it primarily and most
heavily pushed in the one percent
disproportionately strongly because
that's where the most resources are and
that's always how the strategy works but
it's in virtually every school district
in some degree or another if they're
talking about equity equity is a concept
straight out of these critical theories
of identity if they're talking about
privilege privileges the
privileges is your golden ticket to the
bourgeoisie in terms of identity and
cultural factors rather than in terms of
economic factors so that's all privilege
means it's i got the golden ticket i get
to be in the bourgeois class your access
to privilege or the amount of privilege
that you have relational to the the
systems of power and and play as they
would put it
uh dictates how bourgeois how much
access to personal cultural property you
have and of course with marx chapter two
of the communist manifesto is uh
communism can be summarized in a single
sentence which turns out not to be a
sentence abolish
no
abolition of private property that's why
it's not a sentence i should just say
abolish private property but uh
what he actually says in that same
paragraph is that what you're actually
trying to abolish is all bourgeois
property and whiteness in critical race
theory is that is the parallel of
cul racial cultural bourgeois property
and so if you have access to whiteness
by being white
automatically or by posing yourself as
white adjacent uh if you're say asian or
by
acting white
if you're obama
for example there's a book about acting
white about how black people sell out
the authentic black community by acting
white from 2013 in the first chapter is
all about obama and saying that the
social pressures of a white supremacist
society forced him to act white so that
he could achieve a position of power
because you must subscribe to whiteness
if you're going to have access to upper
levels of society isn't that very
bourgeois or whatever so if you have
access to that bourgeois racial property
and sheryl harris a critical race
theorist uh wrote in 1993 a paper called
whiteness as property in case you needed
like really some nails in the coffin
here
whiteness is critical racer he sees
whiteness
racial property or cultural property
that the white people get to decide who
has access to it and who doesn't and
they'll cite well white people didn't
originally consider irish people white
or german people white or italian people
white they expanded whiteness and in
fact if your critical racial
introduction they tell you why they
expanded whiteness say to the irish is
because they said well if you vote
democrat we'll make you white and we'll
give you access to white society
there's a book called how jews became
white folks from the 90s where they
explained that jews actually stole
whiteness and then became
people who are the pinnacle of whiteness
and the trendsetters of whiteness
which has no holocaust
type vibes to it at all um this is how
they think about everything it's
bourgeois property
is whiteness critical race theory is the
study of whiteness as bourgeois property
according to the way that marx conceived
virtual property with the admonition
uh in the communist manifesto that
communism means abolition of bourgeois
property
the whiteness doesn't even mean
whiteness one of those double meaning
yeah whiteness means uh
access to the
it means the set of cultural values and
practices and attitudes that grant you
access
that can only be given by other white
people to be treated as though you are a
fully fledged member of white society
which is in other words that you get to
participate in the
uh
upper crust or the the the super
structural level of society rather than
just in its cultural base a great
example of that by the way would be
where blues musicians were all you know
we're primarily almost all black in the
first part of the 20th century and then
along comes elvis presley culturally
appropriates blues music turns it into
rock and roll and then the white guy is
the guy who goes and pro profits off of
their hard labor cultural labor so the
blues musicians produced the the the
racial base produced a cultural product
that was then uh exploited by whiteness
and the person of elvis presley and put
out in the rock and roll explosion
became a very white phenomenon that
actually then separated itself and
excluded the blues phenomenon from
before it and you can see that this is
exactly again base versus superstructure
thinking who gets access to the
superstructure is people who have the
the kind of bourgeois golden ticket or
in this case whiteness
cultural appropriation is the recreation
that accusation you know you can't have
tacos anymore because it's cultural
appropriation or something um that's a
recreation of that exact same intel
that's where that comes from it's just
been filtered down into
um dumber and dumber words and more and
more racism
over the past century
okay so you said it's and this is being
taught everywhere how far has it gotten
into like major institutions or military
uh very um
it's very far
into them in fact it's very important to
understand what it's being used for
there is a communist tactic called
entry-ism
you make the conditions until
intolerable for people who are
broad-minded or normal or outside of the
ideology so they end up quitting or
getting in trouble or getting removed um
no parallels of the vaccine there either
by the way that's sarcasm there's huge
parallels it's the exact same thing
and you get them out and then you have a
crisis that you don't have enough police
or you don't have enough military and
china's got these wicked missiles and
what's going to happen next well we need
more but you have a new dei hiring
policy in place so you only hire
compliant people and the people that you
excluded don't want to come back anyway
because you've got all these stupid
policies uh that are a constant thorn in
their side and constant waste of time in
meetings and constantly getting them in
trouble for no good reason
constantly diverting from the actual
purpose and tactics and and mission of
the job and so you end up filling up a
you you defund the police to replace it
with a secret place you defund the
military to replace it with
a state state military um
i'm gonna cry
yeah so how far along are we i would
with you ask both in schools uh if we
were going to chart so the the chinese
cultural revolution was from 1966 to
1976
and uh
of course some groundwork was laid
before that but that's ten years so i
would say that if we counted on a scale
of one to ten and kind of used it as a
model i would say we're at somewhere in
the united states at about three and a
half so it's not nearly as bad as people
might fear that it is
but um the the momentum is going to
carry us best case scenario to the five
or six range right now even if we all
wake up and start pushing back right
away uh so there's going to be some
massive damage throughout the western
world and we all have to hope china
doesn't pounce upon that weakness which
of course they will uh unless their
businesses
their their economy or whatever
collapses out from under them
independently which is totally possible
but that's the precarious situation we
find ourselves in but we are we are not
lost
and people are waking up to it much more
quickly than
than um
then if if it were to succeed people
would have to
woke up much later i don't want to say
that there was some plan that when
people might have become aware of it or
anything like that
but um
for it to ex to fully succeed as a
cultural revolution people would have
had to have awakened much later than
they have
so it's actually i'm actually quite
optimistic believe it or not right now
i've been very pessimistic for a year
but the speed at which people have
cottoned on and i think that's a racist
thing a critical race here you can't say
cotton but um
because racism is present in everything
that is actually the first tenet of
critical research racism is the ordinary
state of affairs in society it's
so-called normal science it's a direct
quote um so ordinary state of affairs in
society right so it's in everything uh
but
people are much more aware of what it is
now than
is necessary if they're going to succeed
but this is where
you know what's happening in the schools
makes it is so relevant uh
i don't know what will happen obviously
the the
political top
right now the biden administration the
administrations in many of the
blue states
and then you know we look back to canada
it's totally cooked canada is it like a
six by the way we're like three canada
is in rough shape i left i'm actually
worried about going back like i'm
worried if i go back i somehow randomly
won't be allowed to leave it is scary
over there over a year ago i tweeted i
said here's all my advice blah blah blah
i remember what all the advice was but
one of the things was get out of canada
yeah people were like james has lost his
mind it was like get out of canada yeah
and
guess what right again um
yeah
you can't believe about your homeland
yeah welcome to tennessee
like
yeah
tennessee's wonderful yeah where are you
are you in tennessee yeah i'm in
tennessee how many times are you
oh nice yeah this place this place is
great little beacon
yep
it's fantastic
okay so before
what we one thing we should cover i
guess before we go
is what
if people do start to tune into this and
i think they have as well probably
what happened with covet and everything
got ramped up so crazily but what what
can people do like what if their job is
on the line and they're supposed to go
through this training and they're
supposed to comply like what do people
do
well i can't tell anybody what to do in
their specific situations but i
i would strongly advise that you comply
as little as you can throw if you must
comply throw sand in the gears i
understand if you've got to keep your
head down to protect your family or
whatever
i have little patience left for that
because we are at a tipping point but
i won't say that i don't understand um
exposure is not great for them you know
you see all of the all the pressure
comes when something gets exposed
there's a huge expose that my friend
chris ruffo did for example last summer
of the sandia national laboratory which
is where they also
build advanced weaponry and house
nuclear weapons and things being
completely inundated with these kinds of
trainings and it landed him after he
exposed it on twitter he lands on tucker
carlson he calls on the president at the
time trump to issue an executive order
against critical race theory and that
really mainstreamed the whole fight of
state after state after state trying to
figure out legislative and
uh administrative policy rules to be
able to combat this to protect citizens
from it so
exposure is is the first thing another
thing is that you need to start finding
other people who
are also unsure about this people need
to get together they need to start to
inform themselves share materials such
as this podcast or this debate or
whatever it turns out to be
make up their own minds go read go read
just go read the sources yourself see
what they say you know read it for
yourself i'm not going to try to like
say oh you must listen to me about it go
read it for yourself see what it says um
i would argue to avoid reading the kind
of corporate boilerplate that comes out
of institutions but actually go read the
primary sources go read the books about
critical receiving see what they say
their agenda their agenda is uh in their
own words chase it down uh use my
resources use other people's resources
i'm i'm not close to that but so start
to get together identify one another um
and start to get together and then start
to get informed then start to get
organized if you want to do something
about it you must be organized because i
assure you the communist is organized
they the people that are putting this
into place even if they're not
communists per se are organized they
have a lot of institutional resources
like
being your boss in an hr department or
whatever over you you must come at this
in an organized way that's not
individual uh and then
you know you have to start taking action
whether it looks like you know lawsuits
whether it looks like strongly worded
letters whether it looks like protests
or walk walkouts
whatever it happens to be you know
whatever
the action will have to follow the
specific circumstances so it's not
possible to give broad
broad spectrum advice on what that might
look like you shouldn't be afraid of the
lawsuit though they are discriminating
to implement this stuff
and
the the courts are
still our best tool
um not least because they're non-violent
and can re return results uh violence we
should try to avoid at all costs and so
people should should look in that regard
but they should also be ready to be to
make things transparent
somebody leaked that information to
chris ruffo i mean we know who it was
actually he put a video out but uh lots
of information has been released
privately and secretly to people like
chris ruffo to myself to other people
who have exposed what's going on in
school systems who have exposed what's
going on in um
your workplaces have exposed what's
going on in government agencies with all
of this and
that exposure ends up putting pressure
and eventually some kind of reaction
occurs and then it can end up in court
or discovery processes or people will
back down
if thousands of parents show up to a
school board meeting school board the
seven school board members often
realize that there's a strong community
disagreement with this and then it's not
a factor of intimidation i was just in
utah and there were thousands over a
thousand parents showed up to school
with me they were not intimidating in
any way they weren't yelling or carrying
on but that's a lot of people to show up
and say we don't like what you're doing
and all of a sudden the school board you
know acted differently than it might
have otherwise thinking you know 10 or
12 people might show up and have
opinions no a thousand showed up against
it you know that means that community is
very strongly against it and there are
still a lot of people in the united
states who remember that we govern here
with the consent of the governed and so
when the government show up in large
quantities and say we don't want to be
governed this way there are still you
know proper
lower case r republican
um so not capital republican party but
lower case are republican
people in government but in both parties
democrat and republican in the united
states and in the other parties who are
responsive to that and will will do
something so you know show
you have to get organized get informed
and then take appropriate action given
where you are
if you throw yourself against the
machine you better be ready to become
either a courtroom or and or media
spectacle if you want to have any effect
after something bad happens to you
because it's probably what will come
down the pike
the regime doesn't quite like
resistance and it will probably
resist you harder and then you better be
ready to make them make that be a pr
mess for them in one way or another
okay then last question probably what
happens if we don't do anything
um
it's hard to guess uh communism has
never worked and it's not going to work
because it's based all in false premises
about how human beings in society
operate
this is just another version of
communism um this one's very different
though than previous
episodes because previously we did not
have the levels of technology that we
have now if you read the literature from
the 60s the marxist literature from the
60s they all talk about that when
technology gets sufficiently good
and even marx would have been looking at
this when technology gets efficiently
good you have no need for the laborer
anymore blah blah and so then you can
have all this leisure and you can have
communism and it'll work um
and now machines can do a huge variety
of jobs where we have social media we
have um
coming down the pike
implants like neurolink that elon musk
is talking about where the internet's
hooked straight into your freaking head
um you know so what does it look like if
we do nothing if we don't resist this i
will tell you that a
short order way station is going to be
what it's like in china right now
moving toward china is the first step so
we'll have a vicious social credit
system critical race theory it will be
based on something called esg
environmental social and governance
scores
right now companies have those but
individuals will have them eventually
critical race theory will help define
part of the s the social component of
your esg score your social credit score
will determine your buying and selling
your ability to move
your ability to leave your house to do
things and whatever and so uh
look at what's in china put it on
steroids and if we do nothing that's
where we're going
how bad that can get depends on who the
technocrats are the so-called
stakeholders are that are going to
dictate what people get to do depending
on their esg social credit score
but
it's going to be some form of communism
and or fascism mixed together
and
if you don't want to live in that you
should probably resist it
okay esg is that where did you get that
acronym
oh that's everywhere you google it
you'll find it all over the place it's
part of the sustainable the
sustainability movement or the
sustainability development goals um
esg is
so so the goal is to make everything
sustainable in terms of environmental
concerns and then
social unrest
issues and that's where critical race
theory and post-colonial theory and all
these other critical theories of
identity come in um environmental is
obviously going to be like climate
change stuff and they're going to score
companies and eventually individuals
based on their behavior in accordance
with this and then governance is how
well
are you following so-called best
practices that they set up
but for individuals it will be how well
are you being governed how well are you
if the government says get an injection
today do you go get it today you know
your g-score went up uh if they say you
know stay home for the next three weeks
to flatten some imaginary curve or to
lower carbon emissions for the month of
january
then or turn off your heat for the month
of january then your g-score goes up
because you're responding to the
governance watch this propaganda video
your g-score goes up it's very much like
what they're doing in china
um although they don't use the acronym
esg but esg is not something that i made
up it's not it's it's all over all three
just type it into the search engine
you'll see environmental social
governance esg
scores and you will see that this is in
fact how they determine already how much
asset management or or whatever if you
get listed in what are they called etfs
is that what they're called electronic
trading funds or something like that um
if you want to be in the big mutual
funds you've got to have as a company
your your publicly traded company has to
have highest g score already
um
places like blackrock vanguard nasdaq et
cetera won't list you um
yes
welcome to how this is actually
happening this is the reality of how
this is happening this is why every big
corporation has gone woke is because if
they go woke they get access to the
trading level that makes them richer
they don't care about their customers
because they don't have to care about
their customers because they make more
money off of the stock trading that
happens on the other side of things
whoa
okay i'm looking into that that's crazy
and critical race theory is one
component of the s factor of that
got it okay
and why because it breaks the population
that's why that's why
critical race theory and queer theory in
fact are like left and right hand of the
uh esg
of the s of the esg i should say
wow
that's
insane oh man well if this comes into
effect i'm not gonna be in a good place
all i hate is meat this is gonna be this
is why i'm in nashville yeah your escort
is in big trouble yeah
according to them too that's not even
according to reality right
right yeah well no of course that's
that's the thing is it's it's everything
is going to be determined by
stakeholders and the stakeholders are
people like bill gates so they're going
to determine what right and wrong is and
what gives you a good score it's all
about that legitimation by parology
thing that the postmodernists warned
about
postmodernists were cracked don't get me
wrong they were wrong they were super
leftist anti-capitalist
nuts but at least they saw the potential
for abuse by technocrats
very very clearly
michelle fuco in particular saw very
clearly it's weird how that's switched
around isn't it
oh he's still dead wrong about almost
everything he said except for the
possible threats his solutions are all
terrible
but
as a as
as diagnosticians the post-modernists
were touching upon something very very
important just like the radicals in
occupy wall street the leftist radicals
knocked by wall street were totally
right about the banks but they're still
left it's not jobs
okay
well i think we should wrap it up i'm
gonna go talk to the other guy
good luck with that
thank you very much um if people don't
follow you again where should they find
you and also can you send me over some
of the books you mentioned maybe i'll
link them in case anybody wants to learn
about this
so you so like uh yeah i can do that no
problem uh so the people can find me at
um
conceptual james is my uh handle on most
social media my personal handle i'm most
active on twitter in fact all of my
other social media basically reproduces
my twitter a day late and then um
my businesses new discourses my company
and it's newdiscourses.com is the
website and its handle on most social
media is at new discourses so that's
where to find me uh you'll definitely if
you thought this was interesting and you
really want to know what's going on
you'll appreciate my podcast the new
discourses podcast which is available
through new discourses website and
wherever else you like to get podcasts
so those are places that you want to
keep up with
me okay thank you james we'll talk soon
this episode was brought to you by
nordvpn you guys have heard me talk
about why i love nordvpn i've been
traveling a lot like usual and nordvpn
is a lifesaver did you know serbia has
disney plus band
well they don't with nordvpn
i can't believe some countries ban
disney maybe it was the trigger warnings
that convinced them you know aladdin has
trigger warnings there's the jungle book
anyway if i'm somewhere sketchy not that
serbia is sketchy but if i'm anywhere
sketchy i keep my data or information
safe with nordvpn
it's probably also the right call for
anyone
being sketchy online not that you guys
would do that
it's insanely fast it doesn't slow down
streaming like other vpns i've used i
can't recommend these guys enough it's
constantly useful in many different
situations nordvpn has a brand new offer
for my listeners go to nordvpn.com
tmpp like the michaela peterson podcast
acronym or use code tmpp for their
two-year deal plus one month for 89.
that's 70 off and 3.56
a month
only with promo code tmpp or at
nordvpn.com tmpp enjoy the rest of the
episode
bosh welcome to my podcast
it's a pleasure to be here thank you for
having me
before we get started could you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
yeah my name is vosh well that's not my
real name of course but that's the name
of my youtube channel and i'm a
libertarian socialist i uh do political
commentary and uh play a lot of video
games which really distracts from the
political commentary but you know it is
fun
okay well then let's get right into it
so
critical race theory
i'm going to start with
what is it
and what is it trying to solve
so critical race theory is a
collegiate theory which is uh largely a
critique of liberalism uh which centers
the idea that
um
modern discussions uh around race
relations uh impose a kind of false
neutrality that there's an assumption of
racial neutrality that we've overcome
systemic issues when we really haven't
uh it's a largely esoteric academic
theory um but when we talk about
critical race theory i think people tend
to mean like very broadly colloquially
just
anything academic which
tries to tackle racism i know i've seen
it used really vaguely so
when i'm talking about critical race
theory i always try to find out what the
other person means when they say it
because i'm never quite sure myself
okay
that's that's fair enough i feel like
i'm coming from it from that angle not
entirely sure what it is or what
involves or what it encompasses
that's fun
yeah so
i would say the the more conservative
outlook on critical race theory is this
is some type of
marxism that's infiltrating north
america that's popping up in
uh academic places
all the way down to elementary schools
and that this is a way for marxism to
get a foothold into america
is that
a conspiracy theory or is there any
truth behind that
i do think that's a conspiracy theory um
it is influenced by marxist theory but
then i think most economic and political
theories have been influenced by marxism
i mean so is the civil rights movement
of course that's uh marx was an
incredibly influential writer it's not a
marxist theory though marx was a
modernist and the critical race theory
is generally pretty postmodernist when
we're talking about like the prominence
of critical race theory this came about
in the 80s it's taught in law school i
never reached a level of education high
enough to even be taught it officially
when we talk about young people like
middle schoolers being taught about
critical race theory it's kind of like
saying they're being taught astrophysics
because they're learning about
arithmetic you know you do use
arithmetic in astrophysics don't get me
wrong useful skill but it's not really
astrophysics and it's not critical race
theory either usually it's just
boilerplate liberal
anti-racist ideology which i think is
generally good to teach the kids right
you want to instill virtue in them
okay and then when we're talking about
so anti-racist
ideology and teaching kids that
why and i'm coming from this like from a
conservative perspective for sure but
i'm also open to just learning about it
so why why is that something that's
necessary to teach children
like anti-racism specifically as opposed
to just teaching people that people are
equal right not to not to base on base
judgment i guess based on your race
well that is anti-racism i suppose right
i mean at least i would like to believe
the idea that we're all created and
should be treated equally is a pretty
fundamentally anti-racist idea it's
important though to contextualize things
uh and identifying racism is really
important if you want to fight against
it i mean if you don't know what you're
looking for
it's it's sort of a meaningless uh
virtue signal um after the civil rights
movement passed and you know schools
were desegregated and what have you it
became pretty socially uh stigmatized to
be overtly racist right i mean you know
running around saying the n-word burning
crosses you know not to say it didn't
happen of course but it's not uh it's
it's not as socially permissible but
there were racists back then and racism
didn't just disappear with the passage
of that bill so uh you know things have
been euphemized a little bit and now
when we talk about racism for example at
least in the systemic sense it's not
always about if a person is being racist
usually it's about which systems
unfairly disadvantage people and i think
learning to identify those is critical
because if you never address them you
never actually get to the world where
people are equal you only pretend you
live in that world which i think can
feel a bit disingenuous at times
so what kind of systems
um are we talking about here did you
identify any of those yeah most of them
are holdaways from old legal
discrimination so redlining for example
the practice of you know disallowing
black people from living in certain
neighborhoods i grew up in la and you
can actually see the lines where those
neighborhoods uh were intersected
usually along highways or on one side
you'll have these really nice you know
two-story houses and on the other side
it's like a different it's like a
different world different country
honestly um and if you look at where
black people lived versus white people
in the 50s versus today there hasn't
been much change the housing uh
demographic displacement is a really
like long-term thing to fix and that
affects a lot of other stuff the quality
of the schools that you go to job
opportunities uh a lot of wealth that
white families enjoy today was kind of a
product of the boost that soldiers got
after world war ii all those suburban
houses they got to move into but the gi
bill wasn't really given full range to
black folks so there were all these like
head starts basically that some folks
got over others and those consequences
carried down a long way unless addressed
you know i mean think about it two
generations ago you know some people
were essentially legally second-class
citizens um the idea that all of those
um systemic biases could go away in that
time without really strong addressable
is i don't think realistic
okay i so that seems reasonable um so
then what what are the solutions there
though how are these things addressed
without i say artificially pushing some
people down so i know i i did a podcast
on
harvard and i was talking to an asian
guy and he'd done a bunch of research
into critical race theory harvard and
how
asian people are have to score higher on
their sats just to get in and to me that
looks like straight up racism
so
how are some of these issues addressed
without just going too far in the other
direction
yeah i'm not fond of that system myself
um obviously the goal should be total
freedom for everyone right everyone
should be elevated you never want to fix
a systemic problem by dragging one group
down um reparations depending on how
they're used and targeted are a
potential solution for this i'm a really
big fan for example of a kind of new
deal-esque uh urban poor revitalization
you know in some cities in the united
states you have like suburban areas that
look like they were built ten years ago
and inner city areas that look like they
were built a hundred years ago where all
like this wealth is pooled but none of
it is being spent and that has a lot of
really negative consequences like i said
school quality job opportunity whether
people want to invest there you know
businesses don't tend to invest in
places where there are more potholes
than asphalt um
if you could find a way to invest in
that that would i think do a lot to
alleviate the racial gap and it wouldn't
just be like a black people thing you
know it's a broad
country reinvestment but it's it's
basically about identifying the systems
through which there are disadvantages
and then making those systems less
inequitable for everyone and i think
that pulls all boats up without relying
on any weird like you know
prove your great grandfather was a slave
type
racial targeting
so you're potentially
talking about some sort of tax then
and then the tax money goes towards
boosting up
areas of cities that are obviously
not doing as well as other areas
i'd be okay with raising oh yeah i'd be
okay with raising taxes at least in some
respects you know um but i think that a
lot of this actually has to do with our
priorities i mean there are some obvious
solutions like cutting the military
budget which i think is a honestly it's
like such a stereotype thing for like a
left-leaning person to say but i mean
yeah we probably could and and it
wouldn't suffer you know any
consequences but it's also where this
tax revenue goes you know suburbs for
example cost a lot for cities to
maintain but they don't produce that
much wealth because houses are really
spaced out there's not that much taxable
land relative to the occupation there so
you have this weird system where the
areas of the city that produce the least
money are getting the most money from
the city back a reassessment of our
priorities you know really looking back
into the inner city um i think just
i honest honest to god i think you could
solve a lot of these problems without
raising a tax bill on any american um
but we have to know about these problems
first and we have to care about them
so then is what you're saying and
correct me if i'm wrong but is what
you're saying that
part of the benefit of critical race
theory is it teaches people to identify
these problems so they care about them
so they can be fixed yeah the for for um
the legal system specifically critical
race theory the the main thing they got
mad about right there's this liberal
notion that the law is impartial you
know that it's uh this completely
neutral uh codified like uh
arbiter of justice um and if you look at
how the data plays out with like court
ruling sentencing lengths that kind of
stuff it's clearly not
the judicial system is made up of humans
humans have biases that's i mean that's
just a fact of the world and what a lot
of these critical um race theory uh you
know scholars were frustrated by was
this insistence in their legal journals
that they had achieved some kind of
post-racial um harmony when in reality
what we'd done was paint over
problems that were never meaningfully
addressed that attitude the willingness
to pry underneath the coat of paint to
really look at what's gone wrong i think
that's a really admirable one in all
walks of life
okay
and then
let me let me go to my list of questions
we can come back to that in a sec
so you
you think that there's bat that some of
these ideas that are in critical race
theory came from marxism but like you
described arithmetic leading to
astrophysics they came from there
potentially but it doesn't mean that
marxism is slowly taking over the states
if if only i i'm probably more
sympathetic to marxism than your average
viewer but no
marxism was largely influential in a lot
of anti-racist movements in the west
because the idea of class struggle was
synthesized well onto
the racial struggle that say martin
luther king experienced you know the
idea of looking at the world not as it
ought to be the liberal notion you know
freedom uh equality idealism but rather
as it is which at least certainly in
martin luther king's time i hope we can
agree was kind of a fight for political
power between uh
not just white people and black people
of course but there was certainly that
element to it that ability to recognize
the conflict is essential in order to
address it i think his term for it was
um that liberals prefer a negative peace
over a positive justice you know if
things are quiet
but
you know calm
many people prefer that over things
getting loud for a bit but
then really fixing the problems
thereafter
do you think
so part of the issues i think that i
have with critical race theory at least
on a surface level is what it looks like
is that
kids or people are being taught that
black people are oppressed as a whole
you know and just
putting people based on their skin color
into these boxes and ignoring everything
else so when you talk about you know
inner city areas or
parts of cities
that have issues
that should be addressed
but then you should be looking at maybe
infrastructure and parts of cities that
have issues not the fact that oh in this
city the part of the city that has the
issue is where black people live
because then
i think that breeds problems right i
mean there are poor areas all over the
states that need help so why not have a
bill
that's based on
restructuring
parts of cities that have issues rather
than focusing on race
in terms of a bill i'm perfectly in
favor of that if you mixing up
legislation with race is really messy in
the best of circumstances for obvious
reasons so i'm uncomfortable with the
government engaging in this kind of
partitioning they did it with native
americans and you know the one drop rule
and all that it just
yeah
um but in terms of analysis you know i
think we should have a pretty
no-holds-barred approach to how we look
at these things and if you take a look
at a bunch of these systems in the
united states where black people tend to
be disadvantaged it's not by accident
right i mean if you look back during the
jim crow laws for example a lot of the
laws there that disadvantaged black
people weren't like
black targeted you had for example the
poll taxes and literacy tests uh and
then you had the grandfather clause
essentially like here's a really
difficult reading test you have to pass
you know formerly illiterate slave in
order to vote um but you don't have to
do the test if you can prove your
grandfather could vote right before
slavery was ended so essentially like
without ever mentioning race you have a
system which is basically like okay
white people get in black people
have fun with your test you know um you
don't have to mention race for it to be
racialized and in the case of redlining
or you know criminal justice bias you
have systems which are on the whole
problematic could do with some working
but there is a trend and i think
identifying that trend is important
because it would be really unfortunate
if just through happenstance we fixed
these problems but then in 20 years you
know more of them crop up and you know
the same problems keep re-emerging we
never address the root of it which is in
some cases people are just racists sure
but in a lot of cases i think people
don't understand the relationship
between different kinds of oppression
and how they might um
multiply you know what i mean how they
might compound which is why you know
there are plenty of things that are
totally race neutral that do
disproportionately affect black people
like uh closing down polling stations
because a lot of black people make less
money because they live in areas that
offer you know worse jobs so they don't
often have the time to go driving
further to go put in their vote you know
little stuff like that accumulates and
it feels nonsensical right like because
i think the intuitive response is like
well what you think black people can't
drive but it's all these little things
that build up and at the end of the day
we're people and our behavior is a
product of a ton of influences it's the
role of the state and if people who
analyze these problems i think to
look
uh past the surface and see if there's
something more substantive they could
resolve
okay
so i don't know if you know about
my background and i don't want to
compare myself to a black person but my
like my issue in life was having an
autoimmune disorder and it was bad like
there were periods of time when i
couldn't walk and so that would fall
under you know how able-bodied i was and
i'm not convinced that i guess teaching
people
that they grew up under
oppression basically and that they're
kind of
stuck in that is the way out of that
like don't you think it's probably more
useful for people to learn that
they have issues that they grew up with
and they're going to be issues forever
because life sucks
but maybe
they should kind of fight their way out
of it rather than change society as a
whole
you could just disagree there but i mean
people have issues like you know some
people are unhealthy
and sometimes i think giving people the
knowledge that they can change the way
they live
and accomplish things regardless of who
they are is healthier than teaching kids
oh you've been born under this
you know oppression and you're kind of
stuck there just doesn't seem like a
healthy way of battling some of these
problems well i don't think we should
ever teach people especially young
people that they're stuck anywhere i
think it's important whether you're an
advocate for critical race theory or not
to encourage people to be
fiercely ambitious determined
self-actualized etc
um but i don't think that's mutually
exclusive to addressing the broader
problems i mean throughout history the
most ambitious people were usually the
ones who rose up to conquer the
disadvantages they had to overcome when
we look at history's heroes you know
sometimes they're people who are
uniquely and singly ambitious there's
nothing wrong with that but
whether we're talking about kings and
conquerors warlords or civil rights
leaders you know scientists and heroes
often there is a simultaneous advocacy
for individual achievement and for uh
you know a usurping of whatever unfair
social order they're they're trying to
fight against and that's i mean that's
kind of like the the big thing right
when we talk about politics at least
when i do i'm always thinking how can we
improve upon this what problems are
there that can be fixed it's that
attitude that led to the birth of this
country after all complacency would have
kept us under you know henry for
i don't know however we would be a
colony right now i suppose uh maybe we
would have fought them off after world
war ii i mean i i don't know but i'm
glad we had the war for our independence
and i'm you know glad our founding
fathers weren't complacent about that
sort of thing so i guess i would hope to
encourage both but never to encourage as
i think is often overly attributed but
does sometimes exist a victim mentality
um because it is possible to be a victim
of problems of circumstance of
oppression um but to not be a victim as
as a mode of identity you know you can
be a victor
in circumstances of oppression and
that's what i would want to teach you
know i identify the problem but overcome
rise above it don't let it diminish your
strength
okay i agree with you there um do you
think that
people who are
um i guess
pushing critical race theory do you
think that's the general feeling of
people who are trying to teach this or
do you think that they're teaching this
underlying victimhood because they're
resentful about something
i think if we're talking about proper
critical race theory at the collegiate
level it would definitely be the you
know
the former like determined dedicated if
you take a look at critical race theory
scholars for example these people are
not like quiet or complacent at all
they're quite quite loud and outspoken
in a great many ways so clearly ambition
is on their plate when it comes to like
the stuff people
call crt being taught in elementary
middle school
the issue is a lot of this stuff is just
like let's be real being taught by like
over earnest white progressive karens i
guess like
that's where a lot of it is coming from
like hey listen no hate okay i'm sure
many of them are wonderful people but
i've seen some of these lesson plans and
i mean the way twitter blows everything
up i don't think this is the norm but
i've seen some
where there's usually an overeager white
teacher who's like all right now we're
gonna hand out oppression stickers and
you know uh with the black kids get this
one and you know if you're disabled you
get this one star and now everyone line
up and then there's some white kid at
the front of the class like ostracized
from everyone because he has no stickers
and it's like you know
stuff like that i i don't think that's
conductive to any positive yeah so but i
don't consider that critical race theory
i think that weird cringy over-ambitious
attempts to address social inequality
have
kind of been a thing for a while
more attention is being paid to it now
of course
okay
well i mean it's impossible for me to
know what's going on because yeah you
know you hear things on twitter like you
said um about that kind of thing
happening and that's awful
um but it's not good it's it's very
weird yeah yeah uh what about
do you know what about
what about
critical race theory being taught in
corporations do you think that's
a good use of you know time for let's
say i don't know engineers
i mean like robin d'angelo like that
that kind of stuff yeah
um i guess that's that's pretty adjacent
to critical race theory i don't like
robin d'angelo at all remember what i
said about over eager white women um
it's
so t so first of all we have to know how
this happens okay this isn't like sjw's
infiltrating corporations this is
overpaid corporate consultants you know
running through their budgets and
thinking you know what's the most
eye-catching thing i've heard about in
the news recently that i can you know
spend my quarterly budget on it with
with within my department and you know
robin deangelo is a huge ticket right
now because she's controversial so that
tends to be how it goes i don't think
there are like ceos who are like pro
critical race theory i doubt they even
know what it means or care um in terms
of these lessons i've seen some of their
slide shows where it talks about like
essentially white deferentialism there's
a there's a an attitude on the right
that people on the left think that if
you're white or a man or cisgender or
whatever you should be sort of
complacent or deferential to minority
groups it's an attitude i've never had
um i don't think your opinions become
more right or wrong based on your race
or your you know your your sex or
anything else like that and
sometimes these um
how do i how do i put it it comes off
like a kind of performative
self-flagellation you know what i mean
where people are demonstrating usually
white people how
progressive and woke they are
by
you know making a show of
how aware they are of these issues and
this performativity to me has nothing to
do with real activism it's it's a you
know it's a cell show it's it's what
people do to feel good about themselves
in corporations people should be taught
uh you know don't sexually harass people
um
if you're racist you know will fire you
whatever like be cool
giving them like a big slideshow
on uh
you know weird sort of
watered-down version of esoteric legal
racial theories is i don't i don't know
how that's really relevant i just think
it's like a hot ticket item right now
have you this is kind of a side tangent
have you heard of esg scores
yes geez no i haven't
okay so esg scores i just learned about
these esg scores stands for environment
social governance scores
you looking it up are you saying okay
wait no i think i have heard of this
yeah okay
so from what i've heard and this should
i think this should be concerning from
what i've heard um
whether or not you teach kind of some of
these social issues like critical race
theory or you know gender studies or
some of these things that are getting
into corporations with those slide shows
your corporation gets an esg scores a
score and that enables you to purchase
efts
so invest in efts for the etfs exchange
traded funds etfs
yeah
uh
a rabbit yes
i think i've heard about this um
i have problems with it i think yeah
okay some of these this is i've i've
been i found out about these a couple
weeks ago and i've been talking about
them a bunch because it's kind of
concerning it brings in so
ireland apparently just
started keeping esg scores on their
citizens so
you know depending on how much carbon
you produce that affects the environment
part of the esg score and then social
could be you know who knows what but for
corporations it involves
critical race theory
and governance
well it sounds scary enough as it is you
don't know what kind of what governance
means as a corporation or as an
individual
but
it seems a lot and this sounds
conspiratorial but it sounds a lot like
china's social credit system
and right now they're already in place
for corporations in in north america and
they're already being used on
individuals in ireland
and so the more conspiratorial part of
me which is a very large portion of me
i'll admit but
is concerned about things that
impact that kind of score
like critical race theory right so some
of these corporations it might be a hot
ticket item but some of these
corporations it kind of looks like
for whatever reason they're being
pressured
into bringing some of these
um
social issues into their corporation in
order to impact their scores because
that impacts what they're able to invest
in
i don't even know if you have a comment
on that i just thought no no i i have a
few i just yeah i didn't know the the
good the good time to interject there i
can't speak to the ireland thing with it
being used on citizens i don't think
it's acceptable for a government to keep
any kind of score on you uh if you break
a law that's up to the judicial system
that's that i hate our credit score
system which is essentially yeah yeah me
too yeah i mean that's not technically
from the government you know but it
might as well be again it's yeah it's in
terms of its functionality um so i will
never support something like that in
terms of like the um the corporate stuff
the the details on this in my mind are a
little bit hazy i think
if we were to talk about this as kind of
a systemic issue right um
long it has been the case that
corporations will use these sort of
arbitrary internal metrics to determine
uh who's favored uh in in various
elements of the market you know um i
think like for example you know uh we've
we've seen this whole like pony show
going on with um like uh carbon or like
uh the carbon trades you know where
now i am very cynical about these i
think that for the most part
corporations do one thing and they make
money that is their sole
the only thing they care about they
don't care about
civil rights they don't care about
anything corporations can and they have
if you look in other countries they will
work with nazis they will work with
leftists they will work with well
leftists don't tend to like corporations
for their own reasons but if they can
get along they'll work with anyone they
just want to make their money um i think
that when we talk about stuff like this
we're talking about a very um
topical way
of playing social favorability politics
with corporations
in a way similar to what you've seen in
the past with like i remember gm for
example like changed their logo to green
as part of their new like green
initiative
and then they didn't do anything they
just yeah right and i'm sure their stock
went up when they did that too it
wouldn't surprise me um
this is just another expression of that
and the way out of this i think um
though the market will always play its
own games i think it's important to
understand from both sides of the
political aisle that all plays at social
justice from corporations are just a way
of increasing um share value that's it
that's the sole and only purpose through
which they do anything that's the only
reason their shareholders would approve
anything it's if it serves that goal
public reputation is leveraged in favor
of more money in the future you know
infrastructural investment you know
reinvestment into means of production
all of it if we can acknowledge that we
stop talking about this as wokeness
taking over or you know um
you know this this like new nefarious uh
robin d'angelo um you know the scheme
and instead refer to it i think what
it's always been really which is just an
eternal ongoing pr game that they
constantly play they invent metrics for
themselves to bantee them about and you
know prioritize them over others they
love these games it gives middle
managers something to do
um i don't think
you know real civil rights issues can be
addressed by corporations i think that
at the end of the day it has to come
from us and our understanding of these
problems and i really don't think robin
d'angelo is being brought to any of
these conferences for any reason other
than because the consultants who
recommended her can then list it when
they move over to the next corporation
two months later and get a slightly
higher pay and if we can address it like
that which is cynical corporate banter
then i think we'd all be a lot better
off for it because i get defense i get
accused of defending both corporations
and oh god i hate corporations it's just
you know i just i just don't think it
has anything to do really with politics
outside of money making
okay
that's
i don't know how i feel about that
that's probably true corporations are
focused on making money yeah of course
they are and you know if
if this critical race theory if that
it's true that that impacts their
ability
um to invest then it'd be all the more
reason to push it and then it'd be back
to money in the first place uh gets
headlines too i mean it always gets
attention right like nike's stock price
skyrocketed when they did the colin
kaepernick campaign uh mostly because
you know of of just all the attention
they got for it conservatives hated it
you know so if conservatives left many
people have to i think they just did a
promotional thing with colin kaepernick
right after he kneeled during the pledge
of allegiance oh
they're all those people burning their
nikes and stuff and you know and at the
end of the day you know it's a stock
market bar going up while some you know
corporate leader uh you know
you know with the reptilian camouflage
is like looking at it and smiling you
know i don't it's it's it's i think very
detached from the real issues at hand
outside of giving us all something to
talk about which
i guess it does that
yes if we need more to talk about right
now everything going on uh okay do you
think this critical race theory is
wrapped up in
um other things that are
from what i see kind of also
infiltrating kids at a like a low level
like gender studies being taught to like
kindergarteners
or those separate separate issues like
right-wingers would be like this the
entire thing is just like woke right
it's a critical race theory gender
studies
i don't know what i mean
the world the world's more progressive
now than it was 20 years ago i don't
think that's a bad thing that's just an
ongoing process there were standards
being taught back in the 1930s that
people in the 1910s would have been
taught i mean that just keeps happening
um with regards to gender stuff i i mean
i don't have like a young kid but it
seems like at a lower level at least
it's fairly innocuous you know like
a basic understanding like sex and
gender aren't the same thing
um
i mean i think that's perfectly fine
it's defensible certainly it's a
position backed up by psychiatric and
biological experts in the field so it
seems like uh it would be fair to
introduce it especially since it's so
politically topical you know i feel like
if nobody was talking about trans people
at all like it wasn't this big
high-level political thing with senators
coming out and talking about it i feel
like it probably wouldn't be discussed
as much same with a lot of this you know
race stuff but given that it's so
indicative of the zeitgeist of the times
it seems
fair you know
as long as they're not teaching anything
exclusionary incorrect or offensive i
suppose you know like uh i don't think
this is happening but you know like men
are
worse than women because they're more
mean or whatever you know leave that
stuff out and i'm fine with it
i'm going to read something from so the
the book's called critical race theory
the key writings that form the movement
um
and to tell you the truth i don't know
whether this is pro or anti-critical
race theory or if it's neutral but i'm
going to read this and let me know what
you think
critical race theory rejects the
principle of equality of opportunity its
adherence insists that equality of
opportunity is a myth not a reality in
today's america and that those who
pursue it are misguided the real goal is
equality of results
measured by black share of income wealth
and social standing critical race
theorists reject the idea that sought
after good should be distributed through
systems that evaluate and reward merit
is that accurate inaccurate
oh yeah that's that's definitely central
to a lot of um crt writings though
you're not going to find anything like
that being taught in high schools i'll
tell you that much maybe somewhere but
certainly not standard um yeah i think
that's fair uh
keep in mind before i address that um a
lot of critical race theory was written
directly to be provocative because it
was kind of like the edgiest harvard
students you know and and and professors
writing out against what is essentially
the most monolithic and important legal
institution on the planet harvard law i
mean that's at least it's up there right
that's that's got to be really far up
there so a lot of their writings are
deliberately evocative i think their
frustration was that
um
i'll say this i get this all the time
martin luther king's i have a dream
speech uh great speech everyone's heard
it oftentimes it is cited as a kind of
counter example to what critical race
theorists believe in you know i have a
dream to be judged for the content of
our character not the color of our skin
and
it's it's interesting to me that that
would be the case because martin luther
king in that speech was referring to the
world he wanted to live in
not the world that would exist
immediately after the civil rights bill
was passed in fact after the bill was
passed in a book i think entitled what
do we do now martin luther king wrote
stuff that would later be well
inspirational to future critical race
theory scholars about for example the
essential need for reparations to
address long-term harm so that it's not
merely you're no longer being stabbed in
the back but you've actually patched up
the wound um the need for white people
to understand more significantly the
nature of racism so that we can work
together to combat it a lot of that
stuff i mean i never see it cited but it
was quite evocative i think um
when we talk about equality of
opportunity usually people do so with
the implication that it exists today but
like and this isn't even a racial
perspective that's
very not true if you're born to a
wealthy family everything is going to be
easier on average than if you're born to
a poor family that's not to say that
individual choices and decision-making
don't matter you can fail as a wealthy
person and succeed massively as a poor
person but when we're dealing with
millions of people in the country
statistical averages do emerge race is
one of those lines where it's really
clear that
we we just don't have it you know
um the same with meritocracy which is an
idea i would like to believe in a world
i want to live in not one that exists
the argument of the critical race
theorists is that in a world with
equality of opportunity we would
essentially have equality of outcome
that if there was no systemic bias
between black and white people they
would achieve essentially equal
you know systemic outcomes and i think i
agree with that because the only other
belief one could have is
absent any social biases there would be
something biological holding black
people back which i obviously don't
believe i don't think a lot of people
believe that um but it seems like that
the implication right i mean if we
really did have a quality of opportunity
then
we should be about you know at least in
terms of averages on par
okay
or was i going to go after that do you
think there's any evidence that teaching
people about critical race theory
actually reduces racism
by critical race they were here we mean
sort of the
colloquial
what's taught in like high schools
middle schools just the general like
anti-racism thing or the yeah like
what's being
well i mean my view probably is that the
harvard level has just trickled down and
i mean it once it gets into high schools
like you said it's not going to be the
same thing that's taught in harvard but
i still think it's probably trickled
down so whatever's being taught
now
do you see that working
um in terms of fighting back against
racism
individual racism is
difficult to so educating people out of
racism i think is about a couple of
things uh making sure they live in
proximity to people of other races and
making sure they don't live in proximity
to people who are themselves racist i
really think those the big kickers you
know if you uh live in a diverse
community you are monumentally less
likely to have
you know
racially inflammatory opinions you know
and there are tons of studies that bear
that out um and of course if your
parents are well you know really racist
it's more likely that you're going to
end up racist i don't know how much
education
directly about racial issues deters it
but i do think it gives the people who
aren't racist
a better understanding of the issue and
the tools to fight against it more
substantively for me at least i would
like to see a de-emphasis of individual
racism individual racism exists don't
get me wrong i've talked to plenty of
folks who will just straight up admit
they're racist you know but i don't
really think that's the nature of racism
in this day and age i think a lot of it
comes down to really big abstract
systems that no one individual has much
control over
or
concepts that are so
abstracted that they don't you know
directly mean anything about race back
in the nixon admin for example post
civil rights act you know
we have uh it was at water i think who
talked about how you know suburban was
kind of meant like white like inner city
kind of meant like black you know after
white flight you know the demographics
were evident in the distinction a lot of
white people were in the suburbs and a
lot of black people were in the inner
cities and then add a couple decades of
abstraction on that and it's like what
are we even talking about anymore
learning to figure that out i think is
really really important and maybe that
education can help people do so
focus a little bit less on
explicit overt interpersonal elements of
racism and a little bit more on the
abstract stuff which we should all i
think work arm and arm you know there's
a strong argument to be made for
fighting against that stuff even if
you're white and don't benefit at all
directly from anti-racism um from you
know vitalization of our economy to
uh the reduction in crime because income
inequality is the biggest contributor to
crime anywhere in the world
uh there are so many reasons you know i
i think also abstractly maybe
spiritually yeah i think it's it's it's
good to know that you know you're
linking arm and arm with neighbor to
make the country that you live in the
world that you live in a better place
and this is just part of that
some of those abstract ideas so i can
see what you mean by like suburban and
inner city but
what does fighting against that even
look like like what is educating people
about that and then fighting against it
look like
well i think part of it is that some of
these euphemisms are still used today
oftentimes unintentionally you know the
way people talk about
the inner city colloquially carries with
it a lot of weight that i think denotes
a
maybe not an awareness of but at least a
familiarity with a lot of codified
stereotypes and sometimes it prevents us
from addressing these issues so a good
example would be how we talk about crime
in the inner city now a lot of violent
crime in the united states is caused in
the inner city in black communities and
overwhelmingly this violent crime is you
know contributed to by gang violence and
often the way we address this is through
a sort of blith dismissal you know it's
a cultural issue or if there's something
wrong you know not enough like dads in
the family or whatever you know it's
something like that but there are
actually really direct historical causes
to the place that we're at today with
regards to that particular bias and the
the euphemisms abstract the history
they rob us of the ability to understand
where this came from the drug epidemic
we have right now for example of crack
cocaine i mean this is just a generation
past mine you know
my dad would have been uh just a bit
younger than me i think when that really
exploded um the crack epidemic in the
inner cities and while i'm not saying
like the cia brought it here or anything
like that the way drug policies were
enforced the way police responded to it
created a culture where in some areas
you know drug running was legitimately
the best financial opportunity for a lot
of people and a lot of these people who
did it you know they have sick parents
they have siblings who are you know
living off of uh
ebt cards and school lunches that are
barely substantial i can tell you from
the community that i was born into
nobody uh in beverly hills uh you know
was pushed into drug running out of
economic necessity but
when you're playing averages at least a
few people will in the worst communities
that have the worst economic
opportunities so i guess what i'm saying
is
it's important to cut through
abstraction because it leads to us
essentializing some of these problems
rather than identifying their historical
causes which then leads us to their
solutions
how does identifying their historical
causes lead to solutions necessarily
well first and foremost that it's an
economic problem you know the crime is
caused because gangs fight over
territory because well gangs do that you
know to protect their trade their supply
of you know drugs um but black people
and white people don't actually use
drugs in different amounts by any
statistically significant degree so why
is it all in the black community well a
lot of it is because the
particular dynamics of urban city
construction make it a little bit easier
to run a gang than out there in like
rural wisconsin
but a lot of it is also because of the
relative dearth of economic
opportunities cut through the
abstraction we need a jobs program and
again not targeted by race you know you
know prove your great grandfather was a
slave and will give you a job or
whatever but
so many of these urban areas in inner
cities are falling apart and they are
like
ripe for investment that we
shy away from in large part because of
the stigma inner city you know the term
carries with this weight not just of
race or poverty but of unworthiness uh
and all this is like really subtle
linguistic stuff this isn't to say this
is like some explicit scheme being
manufactured or whatever but
these issues um
they're really complicated and i think
even if people disagree with me on this
which they're totally free to i think
it's worthy
of our time and attention to look at
them in this way because you know even
if it sometimes leads to what some
people might consider like a reach you
know uh i think we're all smarter for
the process
it's funny growing up in canada like i
don't think there is an inner city thing
like people wanted to live downtown that
was about it was like oh you live on the
outskirts you like live downtown that's
where everything's happening it's just
like living downtown
i have no idea about yeah canada i know
i i yeah i know we we just think of you
as our you know our nice uh northerly
neighbors who deal with snow more often
than we do
yeah
okay let me just make sure because i
want to cover some more questions let me
just see what i have here to make sure i
have everything i want of course and i
really do appreciate you taking the time
yeah well i like these episodes they're
fun
do you not feel that the amount of time
it would take to educate people on all
the unfairness that exists
between races
and then if we go outside of like racial
studies
just anything do you think the amount of
time it takes to educate people on
unfairness is actually worth putting in
that rather than maybe teaching people
how to make money
well i think
people should get wound up like trying
to figure out where things went wrong
and
rather than just how to improve problems
that are
you know happening right now
i think it's good to get people wound up
you know these problems are happening
right now i mean we talk about it in the
abstract but there are tens of millions
of black americans who live materially
worse lives uh because of historical
circumstance you know and it's it's
abstract when discussed at an academic
level but on a personal level you know
every dollar um you know missed is uh is
a dinner plate unfilled there's always a
direct
uh a consequence of these things even
though and i admit i mean they're
abstract to me too right i mean we're
talking about like hundreds of years of
history in like whole of america 300
million people that but i know this does
affect people and
being able to draw individual experience
from that abstraction i think is really
really important so like a good example
of this um for example i think would be
like a male isolation you know it's a
really interesting topic a lot of men
feel really like um what's the term
wanderlust the sort of disaffectation
with the world as it is right now i
think and that's like a really abstract
issue i mean if you talk about it at
length in a psychological or
philosophical sense you get into the
weeds but
you feel it individually there's a real
thing at work there i think a lot of
people
at least i can say for my audience
people who have never
had words put to that phenomena before i
think they appreciate it being pointed
out in in those ways and i think we can
do the same for a lot of these issues
in terms of getting people wound up i
guess i like it when people are wound up
i think it's just a good state of being
to be in i don't want us tilting at
windmills mind you
the the the stereotype of the over eager
college student who's out there
screaming that skyscrapers are
patriarchal because they're
phallocentric and you know
stairwells or ableist because people in
wheelchairs can't fly up them or
whatever
is true college students are obnoxious i
will not deny that i will not lie to
anyone and pretend that's not the case
but the spirit there i think is good
after all the enlightenment thinkers
upon which this country's ideas were
built were also annoying uh you know
college students in their time and if
you go back and read some of their
earlier stuff
they were annoying i mean know-it-all
stuck up you know rich snooty boys who
threw a bunch of ideas at the wall but
like hey that's life right in in terms
of what we have right now i don't think
there's a trade-off there i think that
people who are individually motivated
feel a greater drive when they can give
name to
sort of ephemeral abstract problems that
may be hampering them in some ways and i
think people who aren't that motivated
people who don't have a lot of drive
personally which is unfortunate you know
regardless of the race
of that person i i still think there's a
benefit to understanding the nature of
the beast maybe that can you know if if
out of spite nothing else motivate them
i know for example i'm an
anti-capitalist so you know this more
particular to me but i know a lot of
people are really unhappy with the
uh the working world right now
and
if they
sometimes it manifests as this
listlessness you know like wake up at
six a.m go to the job make barely enough
money to pay my bills go to sleep
add infinitive until you die and some
people think well is this all life is
and unfortunately for a lot of people it
will be just as a matter of odds but if
you can understand why things are that
way what forces are at work maybe you
can feel like less of a
a soul wandering through purgatory and
more of an active agent in these big
processes that are taking place
yeah or maybe you should be taught to
stop feeling sorry for yourself and work
harder but i mean i'm pretty
disagreeable so well there are plenty of
poor people who work really really hard
right i know for example that i had
friends who grew up in east l.a
a korean kids you know their moms who
work like three jobs a day uh can barely
make enough rent prices go up you know
i think we have an easy time
understanding when things aren't fair in
the past days like if you went up to a
coal miner in 1872 or like a textile
manufacturer at the turn of the century
you know like you look at them today and
it's like okay obviously they're getting
screwed over you know clearly as they're
being packed into like uh you know
buildings with no fire codes three
families to a bedroom and then they work
for 12 hours a day and they lose their
hands in the textile machine like like
now of course that looks obviously bad
but i think we can live in a better
world than the one we do today i'd like
to believe that in 100 years people will
look back scornfully at the system we
have now and in that future it would be
as tasteless to look back on people
working today and say oh why don't they
just work harder you know they could
have gotten themselves out of it as it
would be for us to say the same thing to
a coal miner and you know appalachia
1872.
i guess part of the issue i have is
what's the solution here because i mean
you said something about being well you
said anti-capitalist i think you
mentioned marxism earlier
but
even like
doesn't that involve redistributing
wealth from people who have a whole
bunch of money and aren't those rich
people just going to go somewhere where
they their money isn't taken
the problem with capital flight
um it's
a studied phenomena i don't know if it's
as much of an issue as people claim it
to be but i think at the end of the day
we live in a democracy and i don't like
the idea of civic policy being held
hostage because we're afraid of the
greed of a few people at the time
there's not really any such thing as a
redistribution of wealth after all the
existence of wealth where it is right
now is as artificial as any
redistributions program would be
the existence of a state for example
allows for the protection of property
rights which is the only reason why
factory owners get to keep their
factories instead of being bludgeoned to
death by their workers and having the
workers take everything for themselves
it's the reason cops guard banks and the
like so the invocation of the state is
what preserved things today a more
natural system of acquisition would
probably be back in the monarchical days
where you'd literally have people
sacking villages for golden art and
protecting it in the storeroom of a
castle but even that relies on the idea
of a monarchy and i mean you can go back
forever but i don't think there is like
a natural distribution of wealth there
are systems and those systems determine
where money goes but our system right
now is every bit as arbitrary as the
system the pharaohs built you can argue
that ours is more equitable which it is
uh but that doesn't mean it's perfect we
can certainly do better and i guess as a
person who
uh speaking charitably here is
sympathetic to some of marx's critiques
i think that if we look at the history
of organized labor we find that a lot of
really great things we take for granted
today were fought for oftentimes at
great personal cost or death
by uh unions and by striking minors and
textile workers back in the day and
while i don't want the pinkertons
gunning down a good working folk today
you know i do think it's important to
remember that as it is the right of a
business person to stop you know paying
their workers very much and go to
minimum wage it is our right to have a
general strike
nothing can take that away from us and a
general strike would [ __ ] the world
really it wouldn't take long at all with
how systems work these days it's a power
we have and are taught not to exercise
i'm saying we broadly i'm not a member
of the working class anymore but you
know we the uh we the people like
writing the constitution you know um and
whatever arose from that a general
strike higher wages whatever i don't
think that's really well redistribution
it's just another distribution of wealth
one of any infinite number
okay well
we need to wrap this up because we could
keep going for a while i feel but let me
okay here's here's something i wanted to
comment on before
we wrap things up um where'd i write it
okay you mentioned this was maybe five
or six minutes ago you mentioned people
um
not going to be able to word this
properly but you mentioned people caring
about topics so if you educate people
you care about certain topics you said
something along those lines that is
butchering it but
my question was
do you feel like the way people are
taught in colleges now manipulates them
into caring about certain topics i mean
even say
you know you're born you don't know
anything about the climate and then
everyone tells you
there are problems with the climate so
then you care about the climate with
critical race there it's kind of like
that with gender studies it's kind of
like that and personally my experience
when i um i went to university i went to
an art school
and it was like super liberal art school
and i started list this really pissed me
off i because i was paying for school by
myself and i took a class on homer and
then i was learning homer through the
feminist lens and it wasn't homer it was
homer through the feminist lens which
wasn't what i signed up for but i saw
that happen across the board and i think
it's worse now so don't you think some
of these social issues are getting
pushed into courses that really don't
have anything to do with them and people
who wouldn't necessarily care about this
issues these issues are caring about
them
because of whatever is going on in
colleges right now
we care what we're taught to care about
which i think is equally applicable to
critical race theory from the
conservative perspective right it's been
around since the 1980s nobody was
talking about it until you know 2021
right because all of a sudden fox news
started talking about it and this and
that and now all of a sudden it's a big
issue effect in america
we
we care about what we're told to care
about i think i don't know if there's a
difference between being told about
something and being forced to care about
something right i mean if you're told
about an endangered species was that
manipulative i genuinely don't know i
mean by nature of the way our brains
work i guess that would sort of compel
me to care but
the difference between presenting
information neutrally and presenting it
in a biased way is
not something i can really discern as
long as the information's being
presented truthfully i mean i'm not
talking like crazy like you know
propaganda state lies or whatever but if
we're operating within the realm of
analysis which is fairly free form
certainly in critical race theory i
don't know where that line is
i guess for me the line that i would try
to look for is
is what's being taught
true and is there value to it being
taught you know are people getting
something out of this and while i can't
speak to a feminist uh interpretation of
homer having not uh learned about the
text myself um
tragically uh i um i i think with
regards to a lot of the progressive
stuff that conservatives
to be fair are upset over i think there
is value to it i think that
there's
conflict arisen where some need not be
and that's a product of language on both
sides i think that
most conservatives i mean there are
racists everywhere i think most
conservatives are not racist certainly
um
they don't like they don't like wake up
every morning things like i hate black
people whatever you know um i think that
the way in which we approach these
issues however has less to do with our
intent and more to do with the outcome
of our intent because and i guarantee
this is true there are probably people
holding up signs which said uh race
mixing equals communism back during the
civil rights protests you know um
who probably also didn't think they were
racist right i mean i guess it doesn't
matter to me what people really think
it's more about what they do and what
they affect
and as long as we're operating in that
realm i think we can de-personalize a
lot which is good because the last thing
i want is for anti-racism to turn into
this game of people pointing fingers and
screaming this person's racist that
person's racist but rather
for us to sit down at the table and
think or i guess say
we should all be invested in the
improvement of our country
infrastructural improvements this should
be like a non-issue you know when it
happens it's good it's simple as that we
should we should look at the data look
at what we have and we should at least
be open to analysis you know there are
um
points of critical race theory i
explicitly disagree with um
and there are plenty of leftists who
fight within themselves all the time
critical race theorists are fighting
against each other all the time there
are you know storied like some of them
have real personal grudges against each
other it's really funny um
it's it's not a monolithic
like ideological totality to grapple
with it's just
things have gotten more progressive
across the board this is one of the more
esoteric expressions of that trend
and if we all can at least engage with
the critique i think we can all come out
learning something from it i know for
example i learned quite a bit from
conservative critiques of uh
anti-individualism you know uh the whole
victimhood culture thing yeah i cause
conservatives make that critique i know
a lot of my political beliefs the
necessity of individual action will
discipline uh have been influenced by
that even though i disagree with a lot
of the conclusions those thinkers came
from i think there's a guy called jocko
willink who who's who's known in the
yeah i'm sure i would disagree with him
politically on almost everything but
there are some things that he says that
you know analysis wise i think are are
actually quite valuable and i just i
think that's the attitude we should
approach things with and if nothing else
it would lead to less inane social media
bickering so that that's probably better
for everyone's mental health
okay well
with that i'm gonna call close to this
episode thank you very much for coming
on if people want to follow you where
should they go
i'm just uh vosh on youtube that's
v-a-u-s-h as much fun as people have um
mistyping it uh i really do appreciate
you having me on
no problem that was good that was
interesting thanks again for coming on
my pleasure
[Music]
you